did you know that Popeye is technically
at Disney film yeah it's one of the few
times that Disney actually worked with
another studio to get a film made and
I'm here to talk about today why because
in my opinion I think too many people
hate on this movie okay it's not great
okay it almost destroyed Robin Williams
career and okay maybe it is a completely
pointless film to have around but with
all those factors taken in ah let's just
look at a story Robin Williams is Popeye
the sailorman he comes into town just
looking to make a living for himself and
he ends up in a giant house with a giant
family one of them being olive oil
played by Shelley Duvall and if you know
the Popeye cartoon you kind of know the
other characters he's gonna come across
there's a character obsessed with
hamburgers named weepy a cute little
baby named Sweet Pea and a giant bully
named Pluto who always wants olive oil
but Popeye is always there to pfeiffer
well that's all fair and good but is
that enough to make an actual story on
it the answer is not really so this
story sort of goes all over the place
one minute it's about him fitting in and
getting annoyed with this tax collector
another minute it's about him entering a
fight and trying to win this big cash
prize another minute it's about the baby
and how he can predict the future
guessing what's gonna win what race and
another point it's about him trying to
find his long-lost father and then
another point is about Bluto wanted to
marry olive oil while also looking for
buried treasure it's the whole Lisa
moves what isn't going on in this movie
this isn't Popeye the movie this is
Popeye the five or six cartoons thrown
into one but strangely enough for all
the stuff that is going on in the movie
it has a very laid-back tone and I think
that's sort of what throws people off
but in my opinion I think is kind of
delight you all the actors for what they
have to do portray their parts fine a
lot of it is just them living in this
town interacting off each other and just
trying to make a living and once in a
while I don't mind seeing a movie like
that in fact I actually love maybe liked
a little bit more if it was more on the
town and they didn't have to go looking
for treasure and all that stuff but on
the other hand it is a
by movie and you kind of got to do
something similar to that you know
Rock'em Sock'em eat the spinach all that
stuff there's a lot of slapstick and
granted a lot of it is kind of slow
because well you're always gonna be
comparing it to the cartoon and it's not
gonna be as fast as the cartoon because
back then technology wasn't good enough
to do that but I think it's okay because
once again it is so laid back that's
Robert Altman who directed this and you
know anything about his work you know
that he usually directs very slow
atmospheric movies and this movie does
have a lot of atmosphere the Popeye
cartoons when you really think about are
kind of quiet cartoons at least when
thinking of the older ones yeah there's
the song in the beginning and end but
they're usually very quiet and a lot of
it this sort of lazily dubbed over but
it kind of didn't matter it just our had
its own feel to it and that's kind of
what I think of with this movie
it's just kind of its own weird thing
and I think if it was trying too hard to
have so much action and adventure and
too many jokes then maybe it couldn't
work but I think because it is so slow
pace it does sort of go at its own rate
it doesn't bother me at the very least
it's an artist just sort of having fun
with his version of something that was
very popular and it didn't feel like it
was compromised he was just so telling
it the way that he saw it but does that
technically make it a good film yeah
probably not like I said it is all over
the place it is pointless for existing
and well the slapstick can't match with
the original animation but I think for
me there's just sort of this nice
environment to it and it has some nice
song some actual catchy songs if you're
looking for this great big grand
adventure that has a lot of comedy that
you're gonna be laughing your ass off
too this definitely isn't the movie but
I don't know if you're a person who
liked to spend some days just sitting
back and chatting with some friends and
doing nothing much else this is kind of
like the cinematic version of that you
know with a few goofy moments thrown in
but hey that happens a lot laid-back
conversations - right I can't help it I
have a soft spot for this movie and if
you don't like it I'm not gonna act like
I don't understand I do a lot of people
can find it boring they can see it is
not very funny but for me I see it as
just kind of a nice film to pop in to
relax
it's got a few funny visuals and fun
performances some enjoyable songs and a
lot of good atmosphere
yeah it's cheesy and corny but for
making popeye into a movie what did you
expect I actually think it's a lot
better than what they could have had at
least for the time period on what
technology would allow now you can
probably make it all CG with a lot of in
jokes and adult jokes and stuff but for
back then I don't think this is half bad
from my point of view it's tough to the
finish